You know how the right loves to talk about
triggering the liberals owning the libs.
And it's all extremely childish and unproductive
when it comes to furthering political discourse.
I agree with all that and yet I still find
it endlessly entertaining to see Donald Trump
so easily triggered by reality, including
the reality of his terrible and diving opinion
polls and his plummeting approval rating.
So let me set this up for you so that we're
all on the same page.
Presidential approval, presidential approval
ebbs and flows, it rises and falls.
And very often it will find kind of a relatively
predictable range over longer periods of time,
like a year or a presidential term, except
when really out of the ordinary things happen.
So like nine 11 under George W. Bush was one
of those, uh, extraordinary and, and unique
things that can shift presidential approval
outside of its normal range.
So ABC Washington Post recently released a
joint poll on approval rating for Trump and
it once again shows that recently Donald Trump's
approval is falling.
People really think the guy is genuinely doing
a bad job in a number of specific areas, including
the economy, trade and so on, and Donald Trump
are re-upped on Twitter yesterday and today
claiming that this is something even that
lawyers maybe should be involved in because
it's another one of these fake polls that
Donald Trump gets extraordinarily conspiratorial
about and goes into these unhinged tweet rants
where he seems to be completely disconnected,
disconnected.
That is from how polls actually work here.
Has Donald Trump tweeting yesterday, quote,
ABC Washington Post poll was the worst and
most inaccurate poll of any taken prior to
the 2016 election.
When my lawyers protested, they took a 12
point down and brought it to almost even by
election day.
It was a fake poll by two very bad and dangerous
media outlets.
Sad.
These complaints are so flacid, so feeble,
so puny and fragile that only the most uninformed
and intellectually insignificant followers
could possibly fall for this stuff.
The polls are fake.
This is the most inaccurate poll.
Everything is always completely hyperbolic
and unbelievable from the sky, and the truth
is there's nothing controversial about this.
ABC Washington Post poll, it shows the same
thing that most serious polls show.
It shows that Donald Trump's high approval
during his term was about 44% pretty normal
for an unpopular incompetent president in
our hyperpartisan environment.
And on the downside, the Donald Trump approval
rating sort of has bottomed out at around
37 38% and that's where it is right now.
It has steadily dropped over the last several
months to 38%.
This is not a rare or unusual low point for
a totally incompetent president in once again,
a hyper-partisan environment where something
like 20% of the population will always say
they support the president.
You've got another eight to 15 who will be
sort of on and off about approving of the
president.
And there's just nothing remotely hard or
difficult to believe about.
This Trump ranges from about 36 37 to 43 44
in all serious polls lately, there are recession
fears.
There's the China tariff stuff, there's the
Alabama sharpie fiasco, which is just embarrassing.
So Donald Trump's embarrassments continue
and polling is a little bit lower.
Um, what is there even to disagree with here?
And then Donald Trump this morning, continuing
the onslaught of just erratic tweets, a brutal
assault on the English language that, that
Donald Trump has been participating in for
years now saying quote in a hypothetical poll
done by one of the worst pollsters of the
mall, the Amazon Washington Post ABC, which
predicted I will lose the crooked Hillary
by 15 points.
How did that work out?
Sleepy Joe Pocahontas and virtually all others.
It's so hard to take this seriously.
Would beat me in the general election.
This is a phony suppression pole meant to
build up their Democrat partners.
I haven't even started campaigning yet and
I'm constantly fighting fake news like Russia,
Russia, Russia.
Look at North Carolina last night.
Dan Bishop down big in the polls winds easier
than 2016.
Donald Trump would be more popular if he just
got off Twitter and was less visible.
It's sort of like the referees in sporting
events.
If you're talking about the referees, um,
that's probably a sign that the referees are
causing problems for themselves.
In the same way, if you don't notice the referees,
you probably default to, they're doing an
okay job.
Officiating this game in the same way.
If you're aware of Donald Trump or radically
tweeting about this, that, and the other thing
all the time, it's not helping Trump.
And when you look at the Russia probe, if
Trump had just stayed silent on Russia, not
tweeted about it, not attempted, attempted
to obstruct all the time, it would have gone
much better for him.
So here's my question to you, am I immature
for finding Donald Trump being so easily triggered
to be hilarious?
I'm a regular critic of the way in which political
discourse has devolved in coarsened.
I want depth.
I want to talk issues.
I want a deep propagandize media.
I mean all of it.
But at the same time, when I see Trump triggered
so easily, daily, like the guy has the thinnest
skin, I find it hilariously entertaining.
Tell me if I'm a bad person because of that.
Tell me if I'm immature.
Uh, I want to hear from you.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show,
and the David Pakman show is also now on twitch
at twitch.tv/david Pakman.
Make sure if you have an Amazon prime subscription
to subscribe with twitch prime to twitch.tv/david
Pakman.
It costs you nothing but it supports our show
and that's where I will be streaming commentary
live
tomorrow evening of the third 2020 Democratic
primary presidential debate.
Oh, we will see you then and also back in
a couple of minutes with much more to discuss
for that